Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Ooh, I'm looking like I am lagging a little bit.
Okay, let me leave my session real quick.
I think it's because I put it on ultra intense graphics.
I'm going to turn down my graphics just a little bit.
Oh yeah, yeah, it's on advanced right now.
Okay, uh, highs.
Oh my god, but ultra looks so...
Oh my god, but look at the little small lighting it gives me for ultra though.
You know what?
I, oh man, let's look a little bit cool.
Okay, we'll do that just in case, just in case.
But, hello everyone, and welcome to Little Nightmares 3.
I'm waiting to see if Chibi is ready to call yet.
Oh, she is ready.
All right, we'll do the shill together.
We'll do that.
The sponsor opening together.
So give me a sec while I call her.
calling her I'm calling her she's not picking up for some reason I call her why is this she picking up hello I call you please respond I call I'm calling you moshi moshi I oh she hung up no oh okay I was gonna be like well she's not picking up and what yeah listen listen yeah I'm listening I was I was busy to call with Barack Obama I had I listen a lot of important business going on I made some time for you but sorry about that oh okay yeah yeah what kind of important business were you doing huh listen listen leave it to the to the oh frick she asked I don't know Listen,
Little Nightmares 3.
Yes!
It's out right now, guys.
It's out right now.
You can...
On what platforms are we able to get Little Nightmares 3, Cheeby?
Let's do a little test.
Was I supposed to read stuff?
Oh.
I've never done that.
Little Nightmares...
I thought the thought the thought was optional.
Sorry, guys.
I brought my child to work today.
She's still learning.
She's still learning her ABCs, guys.
She's still learning to read, okay?
So anyway, Little Nightmares 3 is available now on PlayStation, Xbox, PC, and Switch.
And you will also get a free Friends Pass, and it's included to make it even easier for you to play with a friend on the same platform.
If I was watching this, I'd be pulling out my wallet right now.
Oh, my God, really?
You will spend...
Why don't you buy a second copy right now?
actually tried to in the game didn't work.
It wouldn't let me.
It said, oh.
I was like, you already have.
See, just get a new account.
Get a new Steam account and buy another copy.
It's just that easy.
You know what?
Buy three copies.
And then give two more to your friends.
Give a giveaway, yeah.
Just do it.
Just do a giveaway.
And by the way, or, but you don't, guys, don't work.
You don't need to have a friend to play Little Nightmares 3.
So they introduced a new thing in Little Nightmares where you can actually play with a friend right now.
And that's why I brought my to work my dad to school day mom said your her mom said that friday was my day so um that's why she be here today uh yeah thursday's apparently my day even though we agreed that i see her every other year so i know yeah i know it's like this is my this is i'm so excited to actually see my dad like it's been a hot minute yeah the line at the store for the milk was was a lot yeah sorry it was you know there was a car crash and then you know um i had to really really yeah yeah so that's why i took a while and then you know i actually dropped the milk so i had to go back to the store and uh yeah second bottom milk and it's just it was just a whole thing to you and that's why that's okay i understand i'm patient and that's why it's okay that's why you you might have some Genetic issues,
I'm related to you, so I understand there's a little bit of problems.
Yeah, yeah, it's a little bit.
Anyway, but yes, even you don't have any friends to play with, don't worry.
It also comes in a solo mode with an AI companion.
So yeah, check it out, check the game out.
Also, you're echoing right now, do you know that?
I'm echoing?
I can hear myself from, like, your stream.
What?
Yeah, I hear myself.
me yeah i can hear like i can hear myself from your end is it is it like through my mic or is it like you guys don't hear it oh my god am i going do you have my stream open are you one of my bots okay never mind i might be i might be going a little crazy but i might be hearing voices um but anyway it's okay listen she didn't take her medicine today that's that's a part of the plan i have to take my meds today i um i forgot every time like i see my child i I have to take meds,
but today I forgot to.
But yes, I am looking forward to...
I'm looking forward to playing Little Lumber Street Co-op with Chibi-Doki.
But yes, if you can check out the link pinned in, I guess, Chibi's chat and also my chat.
It really does help the stream.
What the...
What are you wearing?
Oh, sorry, sorry.
You can't even read.
Why are you wearing glasses?
Listen, listen, listen, listen, listen.
Listen, listen, I don't have a tracking link in my thing.
So I'm asking my, okay, Chibi's chat, go to my stream.
Go click her link.
Click on my, you don't want me to give you my link.
I can give you, I'll help you out.
Give me, I'll give you my link.
Yeah, you can, why did no one join?
They're just like, why does like Chibi Doki have like zero clicks on her link?
Did she show up?
Like, what happened?
But yeah, so you click on the link pinned in my chat.
And I guess also CheeVe's chat, too.
And also that's in my description as well.
So yeah.
Have you played Little Nightmares 1 or 2 yet before?
Yes, I've beaten both of them.
Oh, me too.
I think I love the lore of the story in general.
Because it's so creepy.
And also, it makes you think about it.
Because it doesn't really have any dialogue per se.
We live in a society.
Yeah.
We do.
do it's like so we live we live in a society yeah we live and um i do love the the lore of the of it's very interesting laura used to watch these like you know like those video youtube videos where they're like i did that like more explain little nightmares one and two and it's always it's always very interesting but yeah it's gonna be interesting to see what the co-op offers uh yeah yeah the last game had two people so it's like how is this gonna go and like we're with actual people and yeah and like you know this we're not i hope we're not as dumb as the ai's so i know i did listen i think we're gonna do a good job with our combined intelligence yes i think so i think so i think we are like at least like one iq point above the the ai bots that you can get you know well listen ai is smart so if we're one point ahead that's intelligent So like they're better capachas than I am.
Yeah, we have I suck at capachas We have a stopping point, which was like when we were 10, but like AI continuously learned We peaked early.
That's why we played video games very early
But yes, also those are what this will be a short stream Because so we will only be streaming today for today for an hour.
Yeah But we'll continue it.
We will continue it next week, I think.
I'm excited.
Yeah, so we will continue next week, and it won't be an hour.
So we just want to let you guys know, when we just suddenly stop, like, what happened?
It's a teaser.
It's just a teaser.
So then you guys would be like, oh, I want to know more.
I don't know what's more going on in Little Nightmares 3, you know?
Yeah, and like, I feel like both of us were like super excited for this game regardless.
So the fact, like, there's no way we wouldn't play through the whole thing.
It's going to be a good game.
Like, the first two were so good.
That there's no way this one is an amazing tip.
Yeah, I'm super excited.
All right.
Did you select your costume yet?
There's cool.
How would you like to do that?
All right.
I caught dibs on the woman.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I feel like there's a costume.
Yeah.
Cause there's a costume for the woman that's really good.
And I, and I really want to do.
All right.
I'm creating my session right now.
How do I, how do I become beautiful like you?
I think it's already over for you like I gotta go to turkey get some fake tea I gotta go to turkey get a hair got it I'm gonna look like the people out there mine I'll stop there sponsor sponsor hashtag BBO I remember where you're at right now do it next week you tell me next week okay I'll Maybe else next week.
Next week, you can tell me what you want to say.
That's why we are unrestricted.
We are unfiltered.
Yes.
No meds on next week.
I'll go in.
No meds.
I'll let the voices tell me what to say.
Yes.
Yeah.
All right.
I invited you to get it.
Okay, let me see.
Is it through Steam?
Yeah, it's through Steam.
Stupid question.
It's always through Steam.
What are you talking about?
about i know wait can you invite me again wait let's not let it be joined oh my god i have to oh my god i have to go unincognito more oh my god oh my god by the way earlier i couldn't figure out how to do the collab thing again like a loser and i was so embarrassed to dm you and you jump scared me so bad because your model didn't pop up for like 30 seconds and oh yeah it takes a while to load yeah it does that all right let me uh
all right let's see did i do it oh it came to details friends only all right here we go let me invite you again we're friends we really well like that's what pause there like you instinctively pause there it's what the lawyers has instructed me to say that's what the sponsors want us to say oh not oh yeah not just that but also you know your mom and i ironically always makes jokes that she doesn't know who my dad is there's if it's you actually i'm gonna are you actually my dad i was kidding like she'll say like oh yeah like like i'll say like i love my dad and my mom goes yeah sure you're quote unquote dad and i laugh and she just stares at me and i'm like are you okay are you i'm sorry for trauma dumping i it was a moment of weakness it's just i have a tracking link is there a little trauma dump everyone in dokey's chat come click mine no no no wait wait a minute no no click mine i'm the more professional one here i'm i actually had a tracking link also i invited you again okay okay
it's not working i get like a little it says it it says you invited me but okay wait you invite me you create the session in you oh my god you are my dad i that's right child i believe in you oh my gosh all right i got i'm in i'm sinking with with my friend i'm a guy's i'm in the joy session waiting on host to set up the game okay that's on okay good luck okay yeah well leave this to me i mean i would have done it New game.
I want me to worry about it.
I'll be the bird, the chicken.
There's a chicken?
Yeah.
All right.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Waiting for your friend to proceed.
All right.
If you see this, there's a band connect.
Uh-oh.
All right.
It can't be me.
I have fiber.
I love.
You got foot?
Yeah.
I have fiber.
Bro, I'm streaming as a career.
My career.
What do you mean?
Wait, what's your upload download?
What's your upload download?
Like 2000.
That's a fucking lie.
I promise.
No, I have like, like super cheap.
There's no way.
It's 2000.
Hey, I have something flashing on my screen.
I know it's not 2000 upload download.
Because if it is...
You want to do a test right now?
If it's 2000 upload download, you're literally like in the Facebook servers.
You're...
Download is 1,864, and my upload is 2,600.
Oh, it's still going up.
That is like!
2,2,225, it's still going up.
That there's 2,2245.6 upload.
Next.
Is it KB?
I used the Google search one.
Is it?
It's NBs.
Is it KBS?
KBPS?
No, it's NB.
No, it's a KBPS.
What is going on?
That's me.
That's you.
I like my hair.
Oh, you see?
Look at me.
That's me.
Hello, little boy.
Hello.
You want to see my little collection?
Do you want to see my little collection?
Do you want to see my collection of baby teeth?
Open your mouth first.
Oh, I'll never do.
You gotta look at it to see what it is.
Oh, sorry, I tabbed up.
It's okay, I forgive you.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, my gosh, hold my hand.
Hold my hand.
Get back at it.
I don't hold it.
No.
Why would it?
No, no touchy.
Fix my daddy issues.
No, no, your daddy issues will never be fixed.
Oh, ew, you stink.
Let me walk that away.
You stink.
Ew, you stink.
I'm over here.
over here oh oh gross oh god oh god get away did you really think wait i don't know is my audio guys can you guys hear my game oh my gosh you're just like me i always have to ask chat wait my audio is now apparently not showing up on uh uh showing up for some reason give me a sec guys that's okay take your time weird why is this chibi how much did you pay doki for this collab 10k next question yeah i'm sponsored but she has to pay me and join in thanks for asking there's no game audio here too they're lying you're lying because they're you're lying there's no yeah no i i was i uh they were saying there wasn't any game audio on your end as well my stream is so scuffed i have two audio like like tunes like i really it's all one thing so there's no way you don't hear it because I don't know what I'm talking about.
I don't hear it.
How dare you enable this behavior?
What are you talking about?
You don't understand.
You don't understand what they're talking about.
How do I not understand?
I literally see it in the Discord chat.
Ah, Doki, where did you go?
You disappeared.
Doki, I'm right here.
Wait, I can't.
Wait, wait, wait, Doki, what happened?
Wait, you got taken away.
Oh, goodbye.
Wait a second.
On my YouTube studio, your model just went to the void.
Where did you go?
Hold up.
I'll give you a second word.
It's your call.
This is the double the dokey square experience right there.
This is...
Look, I...
My people need me.
You can't.
It's...
You can't fix me.
You're actually gone.
I know what I am.
I know.
I just went to get milk again.
Hold up.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, my God.
You actually...
got taken i don't know where she is guys i how do i fix this your bottle disappeared i think it's here i don't think you have 2 000 uploaded download i do if you want to do it again i'll send you a screenshot okay fix me on your stream first before before anything else can i leave this the the the the v2 thing and rejoin i'm sorry she's hitting things she's mad at me please don't hit me oh wait i can't hit you i would oh thank goodness yeah Daddy's angry.
Hold on, click and leave.
Don't make Daddy angry, Shibi.
Fix it.
Fix it now.
Okay.
That's right.
Oh!
Go!
Your character is like actually deleted from you.
I don't know what to do.
It's actually gone.
What did you think?
You're still here on my end.
What did you do?
I don't know what happened.
If I click you control position, your model goes off the map.
What the fuck?
Like, look, chat, if I click you control position.
Oh, you must have accidentally moved me off.
Like, you must have had something, like, you know how, like, you buffer and then slowly crawl away?
I know, but if I try to pull you back, you don't come back.
from my stream.
Quick pause.
Wait, what's pause?
But first time?
First time.
Ordering.
Alright.
I'm gonna go.
She's not for milk.
But did I actually get ghosted?
I'll go.
There's no way.
I'll go progress.
Oh my god, there's a dead rat.
That's a good gift.
There's gotta be like a YouTuber who knows how to fix this.
You know what?
I need to look for a gift for Cheeby anyway.
This is a good gift right here.
Look at this.
Alright, goodbye.
Do I need you to progress?
I don't think so.
I think I think you're actually banned this is upsetting you're you're gone you got deleted from my youtube studio how did this even happen like hold up can you see my screen oh I'm alive no why would I be looking at your screen I'm because you're my view bot what oh listen it was part of the 10k deal that you've watched my stream well you wanted someone from my team to watch your stream Not necessarily...
Look, look, look, I don't think you paid for the premium experience, Sheeby.
No, it's just a premium experience.
The premium experience is where I actually watch your stream.
The normal experience is where you get someone on the Doki Bear team to watch your stream.
So I think you have one of my interns watching your stream right now.
Wait, I know a scuffed way to fix this, guys.
Okay, I believe in you.
It's gonna be so scuffed.
So I have it where I can't move her model, so I will just shrink it like this.
chat i'm so what i can't move your model but i can shrink the v-tube you can there you go guys boom i'm gonna adjust the audio while you do all of that did you fix it i think so chat does that look good did you did you fix it please say yes guys because like look i made it tiny see it's like tiny sorry all right Alright.
Yo!
Are you ready now?
I'm so ready.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, it doesn't look good.
They're saying no!
They're lying!
Just go!
Alright.
See, look at this dead red.
Daddy got you a gift.
Are you happy?
You got me a chicken?
So this is, you know how I missed your Christmas and your birthday and like your second Christmas and your second birthday and your...
Yeah.
And your school recital.
Well, I got you this to make up for it.
Oh, is it a pet?
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, it is.
It is.
Oh, look at that.
See?
It's so...
Look at that.
How do I pep it?
I don't know.
Oh, look at back massage.
Chiropractic.
I have scoliosis.
Look at that.
Hashtag three curves.
Get that trending on Twitter.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Goodbye Chris I have to quit the bow and well, you have a bow Oh do some oh my god you have a bow you can't shoot me though cuz I I tried to I tried to There once I think I can hit the spell I think wait where you're new hit it it looked at my character looked up Yeah,
hit it thank you hitting it.
Thank doc.
Okay.
I don't think we're supposed to do anything here How about here?
I want to play that hit that hit that Go see look at that Let's freaking go teaching my child I saw you got close to the edge and I wanted to go further than you Okay, wait there.
Okay.
I'm putting that teaching my child basic problem-solving.
I think I failed.
I think I failed as a parent This place does not have enough safety regulation.
All right It's okay one day she'll learn Alright, I'm waiting for you.
This is Arizona.
Is Arizona okay?
Is it?
It did.
We're New Mexico.
Look at this.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's a dead man.
Wait.
Cinnatize.
Oh, yeah, he would have eaten us.
Get him.
Yeah.
Let's see his money.
That is going to teach you how to make some money today.
Oh my god.
There's so much food.
Look at all.
all this.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's just a box.
Can I carry this?
Do it unboxing.
It's... Oh, I can't carry this.
Alright, let's go.
I wonder how you died.
I mean, you did die of starvation, obviously.
I hate it.
I got stuck on a one-by-one block.
Look at this speedrun strat.
Yeah.
Please.
You think we're gonna die here?
No, no, no.
Well, I did twice.
But no.
Oh, wait, there's a crow.
Eat it!
Oh, I should have shot it.
Oh, there's nothing in here.
I got a key in!
Wait, how did you pick that up?
I pressed, I'm using mouse and keyboard.
I clicked it.
Oh, well, you just click it just like that?
Yeah, I'm gonna click it.
Grab this one.
Wait, it can't click this?
Grab my can.
I'm gonna smash it.
I'm angry now.
Look, high-five me.
Don't leave me hanging.
I got it.
Oh, it's this don't leave me hanging high five me don't don't leave me hate don't leave me hit don't leave me hang Oh, sorry, what do you say no, it's okay.
It's windy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, like sorry I was I've been working so hard trying to try to make money for this family right now It's Skeleta.
All right, I'm climbing up the ladder Oh, yeah, I'll go second.
Sponsored, I won't say anything.
Yay.
It's like I'm the main character of the story.
I got a good view, though, so jokes on you.
Of your dad?
Yeah, I get to see your feet.
Your dad's feet?
Okay, I'm going to kill myself because I didn't realize it.
I forgot.
That's our relationship.
Night there.
I just want to say, this ladder is very, very, very, very tall.
Frank.
Oh, you're gonna have to wait for me.
I'm still climbing by the way.
I am still climbing.
I'm here now.
Don't leave me.
Sponsored by Bandai.
Thanks for sponsoring us, by the way.
Click the link in the pinned message.
Yeah, click the link.
All right.
You still have to keep climbing, by the way.
The ladder.
Yeah, the ladder.
I'm still climbing, by the way.
I'm still climbing.
It's pretty.
You should have dropped off halfway.
I'm still climbing.
I feel like I'm inside an air fryer It's so like hot and dusty.
Oh, are you there yet?
I'm still cuz I I'm almost there Wait, I think wait, you what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I was like to destroy this.
I'm teaching you a life lesson right now Don't trust anyone not even your own fault I'm screaming like, huh?
He's so strong.
Big strong.
Daddy is here to help.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, why did I... Look, I'm gonna hit that chicken for you.
Is this offensive to you because you're a chicken?
No, it's okay.
I eat my own kind.
Oh.
It's called survival of the fittest.
Please don't take away my dinner from missing.
Alright, let's see.
RT and grab.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Now move.
Wow, look at her go!
Look at them, do you see the chicken feet?
What?
Look in the box, the little chicken feet sticking out.
Oh, yeah, there is!
It's dead!
Oh, wait, wait, what's over here, though?
Let's check over here real quick.
Oh, look, there's a dead body out there.
Oh, what do I have?
Wait, what do you have?
Oh, I picked up a little baby doll.
Oh, maybe it's a collectible.
Hey, go jump to that.
Oh, to the big, like, piece of ham?
I don't think I can...
Oh, wait, no, no, over here, you don't see that?
that ledge over there jump over there oh yeah yeah you see that i think you make okay can you push me can you help me yeah okay all right ready yeah i'm ready three two one wait can you not jump can you not jump over there no there's an invisible wall there's an invisible wall yeah oh yeah you're right stupid yeah idiot i i wish there was a push mechanic I'm just gonna say that.
Yeah, you think I didn't fucking know?
What?
Yeah, that's so cute.
Who the frick is this?
I think it's just a regular guy.
Oh, he's definitely dead.
What?
Oh.
Did you fall off?
No.
No, I checked an Ender Pearl.
I got you something.
Oh?
Where did you get me?
Where did you go?
I got you something.
What is it?
What happened?
No, it's gone.
It's, it's, uh, it's gone.
You fell off.
You fell, didn't you?
We have to move this thing.
Where are you?
I'm right here.
I think, oh, maybe, oh, shoot the rope.
Shoot the rope.
You see that?
Yeah, yeah.
Watch this.
360!
there she did it follow me follow the lead i understand all right as a respectful adult i'll wait for you to go up before i i watch this i'm gonna jump to the rope all right i'm watching ah you did great did you get the rope no Oh, wait, what's this?
There's like random stuff here.
Yeah?
Oh, wait, there's another rope.
Alright, it's time to do your special talent.
Alright.
Right here.
You ready to be impressed?
Yeah, I'm ready to be impressed.
You ready for this?
That's right.
I mean, I feel like your technique needs a little bit of work, but I guess that's our...
I've heard that before, actually.
It's okay.
You know, maybe one day you'll get it right.
Thanks.
At least you believe in the one day.
Well, I just say maybe.
Not like one.
I'll take it.
That's not that bad.
Careful, careful.
Oh, what's going on?
I don't know if you know this, but you can fall off.
How do you know that?
I would know.
I'm just trying to warn you.
How- how did you know that, gee?
Listen, it's- and it's also a really far flaw.
What is this thing?
Wait, can we grab it?
I don't know.
It looks like we can spin it or like attach something to it.
Thanks.
Wait, oh, maybe?
Hit it!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh!
I knew I'm so smart.
You spin me right around, baby, right around.
Like a rock baby, right, right, right, right.
Ah!
That's tight!
That's so messed up!
Why did you jump left?
You couldn't jump to the right.
Why did you?
Why did you jump to the right?
Why did you jump into the pit?
Open the stick.
It's 50-50.
She better worry about you.
We're gently.
She be I worry about you.
Really?
Do you care?
I think you have zero survivalism.
things yeah all right I open the door from yours okay I'm going in I'm going in the leap of faith yeah she believes too much oh I gotta pull that maybe this yeah oh gosh ah I got some statues over here can you see me no oh oh yeah I can all right what you doing right now what are you doing with men out there don't worry about it or the way what are you doing with those random statues random strangers how do we shoot this chicken shoot the chicken there's a chicken yeah I don't think I what is I okay I'm gonna turn it all the way yeah and then maybe there's a way to maybe there's a way to lock it in on your okay there's a rope you see that rope no okay chibi you see that rope in the center yeah all right you know what to do guys we're figuring it out and look now this should stay right yeah yay and i was like why is this guy having no hand listen i was wondering how that guy could like white he's got no hands all right are you trying to say people with no hands can't white well no i'm
just saying like i was just wondering i wanted to ask him how he does it oh wait i think oh we need to put this on oh yeah all right you got this i believe in you teamwork makes the dream okay teamwork yeah let's go we're working together good job i'm so proud of you guys see i'm such a i'm so pro woman it's insane I believe in women's rights and wrongs.
Anyways, move out the way.
I mean, it's all about equality.
Exactly.
All right.
I go up.
Oh, we need a key.
Oh?
What key?
Wait, there's another little thing you jump on.
Yeah?
Where?
Oh!
Yeah, we need a key.
One day, you will develop trust issues.
All right.
Sneaky, sneaky.
What do you think are in those sacks?
What sacks?
All these sacks on the wall.
Which one?
What do you think is in them?
There's no sacks in the wall.
What are you talking about?
Over here, these sacks on the wall.
What do you think is in them?
I don't see it.
You don't see the sacks?
No.
Where are they?
Oh, maybe like we see different things.
Maybe like, uh...
The walls are full of voices and like...
Yeah, yeah, cause mine is just a wall.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Okay, but if there were sacks here, what do you think they'd be full of?
Yeah, but okay, describe the sacks to me.
There's sacks, and there's like a bunch of them on the wall.
Okay, what color is it?
Sack color, like brown.
Okay, what color is the sack?
Brown.
Okay.
Is it like one giant stack, or is it like multiple sacks?
Like, there's like 30 sacks.
Wait, you counted them?
No, like, I need to guess them.
Do you want me to count them?
Oh yeah, sure.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen, fourteen, fifteen, sixteen.
I'm done.
I can't do it.
It's like thirty.
Okay, but yeah, no, I see the sacks.
You do say, Papa?
Yeah, I see the sacks, yeah.
Okay, what do you think is in them?
I think most likely just bodies, right?
Probably.
Like, I don't know.
Oh, we just actually kissed.
I feel like, I mean, we just...
You're dead?
You know?
You
know?
Yeah, like...
Like what?
I just accidentally kissed my dad.
Sorry.
We're on the next family, uh, the family cookout's gonna be really awkward.
Oh, hey.
Was that also an accident again?
Was that?
Oh, we just did it again.
I don't think it's an accident anymore.
All right.
Oh, excuse me.
Oh, whoa.
Excuse me.
Oh.
You okay there?
This is...
I need feather falling.
Try to figure out what to do.
Oh yeah, we're supposed to do stuff.
Can we climb the sacks?
No.
Oh!
I just think it's happening to my left.
It's time to shoot.
Alright, you get on that.
Alright.
Never heard a woman say that in their mind.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Jump on it.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm violent.
I'm violent.
Alright.
And then I'm going to take you.
I'm going to... My people need me.
Yeah, I'm going to take you to where your people need you.
Wait, no, no, no!
Are you ready?
I'm scared.
Okay, I'm scared.
Go slow.
I believe in you.
Okay.
You gotta...
You gotta be a brave little girl now, Cheeby.
This is where you're gonna start growing up now.
What do you see up here?
It's a lever.
There's a lever.
Alright, turn on that lever.
Boom!
What did you do?
It descended an escalator.
An escalator?
Where?
Here, I'll descend it right here.
Oh, okay.
In front of the sack wall.
Oh, I see.
Oh, it's an escalator.
Yeah.
At the bibliotech.
Oh, bibliotech.
Yeah.
Buenos dias.
Andle, Andle.
Vamonos.
Those chicas.
All right.
Oh, I can't say that word.
I was going to say a word that I can't say.
No, it's okay.
I held myself back to it.
There were several words I wanted to say.
All right.
Oh, we're so strong.
Dude.
Look at us.
Go.
This is unlike real Wi-Fi.
Oh, there's the crow.
Hello, sir.
Oh, shoot him!
Shoot him!
Shoot the crow!
It's time for exam, Mr. Chicken.
Yay!
See, I got the healer.
Let's eat him.
I don't think there's any much meat on him left.
Also, isn't he like...
I feel like he's too malnourished.
I don't think it's good meat for our bodies.
I think he's dead, yeah.
It's probably rotting.
Well, I mean, like...
I mean, all meat is technically dead meat, but I just feel like... I mean, he has great skin.
So I feel like it'll be not good nutritious for us The fresher they are, the better it'll taste Maybe they'll have like a Wendy's around here Yeah, maybe, yeah, Wendy's for human bodies That sounds like a good time Or maybe we can Oh, watch out, there's all the
Alright, I've got the key Did you die?
Did you die?
Why did you die?
Every time you've fallen, you've never said anything about fall damage.
Wait, you didn't know I was sorry?
I didn't know.
No, I knew on some, yeah, I knew on some areas it was, yeah, because you fucking fell into that bitch.
Oh, no, I died every time.
Every single time I died.
I didn't realize that.
I didn't realize that we would have fall damage.
Open sesame.
What's the magic word?
Really, please?
No.
Try again.
What's the magic word?
Fish filet.
Nope, try again.
What's the magic?
You only have three tries left.
What's the magic word?
Oh, frick.
Oh, frick, can I have a hint?
Can I, like, is there a theme in this movie?
Oh, oh, the code word is sponsor.
Check out that pinned message, guys.
Click it.
There we go.
Someone.
I tried to.
There you go.
and and whose link do we click that's right go click it all right where should we go look I'm twerking sorry they're my sponsor click that link edit it out edit it out why are you looking wait wait why are you why are you looking at my butt i don't think we're supposed to push this wait let me yeah no wait what's over here bucket can i go in the bucket oh my god i gotta take a leak in the bucket it's the leak bucket maybe over here oh maybe close this oh wait no that's just behind it oh maybe maybe we're dumb
We peaked early.
We did peaked early.
That's why we're not AI continuously.
Oh my god.
Wiki's alive.
511 versus 6 foot.
Oh no.
Oh look, can we die here?
I don't think so.
No, I think he's just... I think that's a warning.
I think he's just walking away.
Yeah.
Wait, I got it.
What is this?
Oh nice pot.
Yeah, no problem.
Oh nice pot, dude.
You got a souvenir for the event.
Yeah, that's a souvenir.
Okay, push.
Push.
Dude, I like this so far.
More snacks!
Wait, those are potatoes?
Are they like always, are they like turned into stone or something?
Like, if they see us, we get turned into stone?
Yeah, it looks like they have psoriasis like me.
Yeah, wait, wait, that's not...
So, no, never mind.
Wait, no head.
No head.
What is the sponsor stream, so?
Wait, what's the...
Wait, I think here.
Oh, can you go up?
Oh, never mind.
We're a bit too heavy.
We're a bit...
What?
There's the... It goes up!
Yeah!
Oh, what's in there?
I think there's some surprise in here.
Can I break it?
Okay, we can't break this yet.
What about this?
If I hit enough things, it'll work.
Okay, maybe it's not this.
Why is it kind of ominous?
this I think there's a stool maybe no what are you doing to that stool I was trying to pick it up I don't think we go down I don't think we go I think I think there has to be something we're missing Wait is there anything we can push Oh maybe Can we push this?
Wait oh my god come over here He did not push this Oh my goodness It's poor
What's that?
It's a piece of ham Oh my god oh it's Nipra Alright let's get All right.
Merry Poppins, y'all.
No!
Oh, okay, we got it.
Nice Batman reference.
Wait, what?
Oh, if you, like, leave just a little bit.
Then it, like, then you go down straight down instantly.
Wait, there's something, like, to our left.
You see that?
You check out the thing at the left?
Dude, my paddock-a-dock is weighing me down.
Oh, it was nothing.
My paddock-a-dock.
I think it's all the way up.
Yeah, you get that for me.
How do I go further?
You just follow the wind.
My hands are in the air.
Stay in the center.
Look, look, look, look.
My hands, my hands are in the air.
And I...
Look, look, look, look.
Are you...
Stop.
Follow just follow the air.
Wait, I see I got it.
I got it.
I found the center.
I did it.
I did it Goodbye No, no, no, no wait.
Goodbye Don't sit wide away from me.
Don't sit wide away from me.
Get back Maybe you should have learned how to use an umbrella.
Oh my god.
I'm not strong enough.
Where's my AI when I need it?
Where's my- No, no, no!
I'm a game journalist.
I'm doing how you do me.
I got you!
No!
Stay!
I got you.
It's my bad internet.
I only got 2,000 upload downloads, so it's a lot.
There, see, I did it.
I restarted my router.
We're good.
All right.
How do I ride this thing?
How do I ride it?
Oh!
Oh, I click on it!
Did you do it?
Did you understand it?
Oh.
We're cutting that out.
Here you go.
That's right, you little careful princess.
I see that.
There you go.
My little princess needs some man-wee muscles, I see.
Careful princess.
Oh.
What is it?
Oh, it's people stopping.
It's the people, I think.
Is it?
That does not sound like people.
I think it sounds like a...
Like a dog or something.
Like a dog?
Dog.
God.
Is there anything else here?
Wait.
Wait, you see the, there's a rope thing over there?
A rope?
What?
How do we do this?
Maybe we gotta stand on.
I don't think we can stand anywhere.
Maybe we both stand on this?
Oh, oh, we have to jump, we have to jump down.
Oh, jump, jump!
Use the power of gravity.
That's okay.
Oh, X.
Oh my God.
We finally learned how to run.
Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Well, one of us finally learned how to run, but...
Okay, let's lock it.
We mean...
I'm not going to name names on who threw there, but...
Yeah, I'm not going to name names, but let's come on.
Like we don't know if you don't know it was it got was all up there, you know, everything happened so fast Is he collecting these mini figures?
Okay, okay, oh jump it's faster.
Yeah, boom.
There we go.
We figured oh Boing boing boing.
Oh, I think we did oh brother.
Oh, no.
Oh, I put it up.
Oh, I put it up What's the point?
What's the point?
I use a controller.
What do you mean?
a different input from you.
Oh, it's E!
It's E!
What the f- I'm not using mouse if you worry.
Alright, I made a hole.
Don't worry.
I did all the hard work.
Okay, um...
Wait, cutscene?
Yeah.
Or did I just like die?
Yeah, you died.
Yeah, I think you died.
Oh, it's us!
I like your head.
you're in a gourd oh thank you all right here you go wait how did you die get the mining yeah like a transporting me back here for the mines all right oh yeah yeah i think we had to jump down
okay yeah it's good okay there's a weapon down here do we need to pull it
trying to get you to jump that because that's how i died
i'm helping you clean careful princess all right i can't you want me to bash your head in you want me to let's see this wall is made of stone we're gonna need a stone pickaxe here or a wooden pickaxe all right bam careful princess bam bam don't worry she's so independent here All right,
get your umbrella out.
Do you remember how?
Wait, I can use the umbrella?
Wee.
So there's no fall damage now.
Look at that.
See, lesson number one.
Get an umbrella.
No.
Open the mower.
Open sesame.
Oh, it's the eye from the first game.
Oh, oh, that's how they're turning the stone, remember?
I remember.
It was like in the...
Yeah.
Okay, we have to use this to recover.
Okay.
This is how I got Saraius.
Oh, we're okay.
We're okay.
Excuse me.
What does this do, though?
Oh.
Is this a good thing?
Oh, I don't think that's a...
Oh, it's okay.
He's making a path for us.
He's both playing with Legos.
Oh, we go straight down.
Oh, yeah.
See, he must be a nice guy.
You know?
He's so nice.
Nice to us.
Come on, this way.
Yeah, just because he's big doesn't mean he's bad.
Yeah, it's just a little, you know, giant, but...
Well, so it's hard being six foot, too.
This is a long-ass elevator.
Oh, never mind.
That was not.
Hello.
What the frick?
That's so creepy.
Look.
What is it?
They were...
Ew, they're squishy in this head.
The balls.
Why are the balls on him?
Step on him over here.
They're squishy.
Ew.
gross wait that's what's inside them all along do you think it was a bug that did this to the oh stop oh my god i think he laid eggs in him yeah yeah yeah that's their nest i think we just killed little baby bugs you're a murderer you're a murderer i don't want eggs in my brain unless they're soft boiled because those are good what are you doing wait wait wait what is this area or shoot it oh wait am i supposed to oh crouch I was like,
there's a hole here, but we're so tired.
Oh my gosh, look at all the eggs.
Squish them.
I'm saving the world.
I'm squishing the bugs.
We're going to destroy the ecosystem.
I really hope they don't remember that.
This is the only way I really don't like bugs.
This is actually creepy.
Wait, are there going to be other bugs?
Oh, they're all using the carcasses as like slowness.
That is actually terrifying for me.
Do you like bugs?
No, I'm actually, I'm so, I'm really afraid of ants.
I just uh Do you know crane flies?
I'm terrified of crane flies.
What's what's their dog?
Like that Oh, they're beetles.
Oh, they're beetles.
Oh, that's not bad.
It's not as bad.
I like beetles.
I like
I think princess don't bite.
I I think this might be a might be a bad beetle.
Just maybe just just just a maybe one of us had like a ranged weapon to shoot at there One of us didn't step on all the eggs.
Hmm?
If only...
If only someone didn't step on all the eggs that the beetles were so hard today.
Careful, princess.
Alright, I got this.
I'm gonna shoot it.
Watch this.
Alright.
I'm watching.
I'm spamming.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you're doing it!
Oh, you gotta hit it!
Oh, wait, they get back up!
We gotta wobble combo this, motherfucker.
We, wait, we have to play like a team?
I mean, we can't just enjoy this game solo?
Come on, all right, all right.
Listen, here we go.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Let's decide.
I'm paying attention.
For real.
I'm shooting the floor.
Okay, you, you, you, you, you.
Yes!
You have to jump!
Team kill!
Alright, where's the next one?
Look at all that chickens!
Ah!
The demon!
Look,
I can't really do anything if I don't see any bugs on the floor.
Oh, that's all I'm seeing, TV.
Listen, listen, listen.
I thought that.
Listen, listen.
I shot the floor instead of a bug.
Alright, wait, isn't it auto aim?
No, I have to get close on the floor.
I think oh, okay, I'm pretty sure this one is the land here All right, I'm ready Okay, okay Boom!
Yeah, and then I'll go here at the next one Trambo Wamba, trambo The right to the right to the right to the right Yeah, get him And then there's another There's the right There's the right
We both said the directions that were not right No, I said left What do you mean?
It was in the middle about the left Oh my god It's in the middle, not the left.
You were literally right there.
What do you mean?
It's auto-aims if you're under it.
I wasn't close to the...
Oh, wait.
Oh, you have to be under it?
Yeah, you have to be, like, right next to it or else my character goes, I'm going to hit the floor.
Alright, I believe this, guys.
Alright, I'm watching this.
First try.
And then over here?
There you are.
I got one.
Nice.
Get him.
Go on there, chicken.
and then the last one's over here i've got you there you go there you go and then there's a fourth one there's a fourth one right right right okay nice combo we did it now we're now we're what actually you're right i'm a little hungry though honestly i mean like bugs are very good nutritional value if you think about it you want to know funny story uh i was at uh a convention with my dad one time And he fought all the stuff on...
Oh, well, my...
The guy who...
Oh, the guy that your stepdad.
Yeah, my stepdad.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
He thought all the things on the tables at the convention were free.
For some reason, because he'd never been to a con before.
And we were at...
I think it was like...
It was like an energy drink company.
It was Gamer Sleptor Advanced GG.
I can't remember.
And my dad stole a candy bar.
Oh, my... Oh, like, it's just a candy bar.
Okay, that's not that bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He thought it was free.
Don't worry.
I messaged them.
They said it was okay.
And I take it home and I feed it to my mom and my grandma.
We're like, oh, it's actually pretty good.
And it was made with a cricket flower.
We had no idea.
I'm just in fair.
You know, like, red, the color red is like made on a...
Yeah, made... Like, you know, the color red is, like, made of crushed beetle juices.
Yeah, a lot of makeup is made out of the movie.
A lot of makeup is made out of bugs.
That's true, too, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh.
You got it.
I think it's like one of...
Yeah, I think like only one of us can go in one at a time.
One at a time.
One at a con.
Oh, get the eggs.
Oh, yeah, make sure.
Squishy, squishy, squishy.
Don't leave any...
Don't leave any child behind.
I'm stinging.
That's what they always mean.
Don't leave any child behind.
Yeah.
If they're all dead, they can't leave them behind if you think about it.
a pillow that was so poetic i can't leave them behind they all bad exactly oh this is oh god oh i think we get closer to closer to a nest or something wait what i don't like it oh what are these are these bird heads what are these oh these are bird heads are they how do you know this one because it's a bird head how do you know or they just be a really sharp rock ow it's an ice cream oh up here up here beer oh yeah it could be like ice cream cold Yeah.
Up we go.
Up, up, up.
Dude, I do not have the strength to do this in real life.
Do you think you could?
You know, like, I know I definitely don't think so.
Like, have you ever, like, were it?
I know, like, I've seen this, like, American cartoons.
I don't know if it's real, but have you seen those, like, P-classes in American cartoons where they have to, like, climb up a rope in the middle of the street?
Yes, like, in the movies and stuff.
Yeah, have you ever done that?
Is that real?
I went to school mostly overseas.
don't know i don't know yeah when i came to the states and like i went to high school here it was mostly like dodgeball track i was on the tennis team so like a lot of tennis yeah because i'm like i don't because i feel like has like any kid died doing that you know probably because i was like that doesn't look very safe yeah oh it's real like how do we stop a kid from dying from like one time one time the army came to my school to do military tests and they had a pull-up and i couldn't do it and i cried anyways let's continue on our adventure how old were you 13 oh i couldn't do a single listen i i at the time i weighed like like like i was also like 20 pounds oh my god i know i couldn't even it was really embarrassing also like were all the children watching yeah so and also the like scouts and they were not oh did you get scouted no well my grades were bad enough that they were interested but then they saw my physical ability scoliosis so you can't get like the the free tuition and
shit yeah that's unlucky i know it's a skill issue it really is but that's okay that's why you're a streamer now oh i did it yay yeah we did weightlifting on every wednesday and i the bar which is 45 pounds it's fun i'm proud of you knock this over knock this over wait what boom whoa oh my god you're becoming stronger oh do you hear that i hear it yeah okay he's even got pushing
oh run run run run run run run run wait he has no face We gotta go find the box.
Oh my god, we gotta be buying the box.
We're gonna turn in the stone.
That's creepy.
Yeah, he had no face.
Did you see that?
He was balding, too.
Do you think he was she was balding?
Maybe he watches us.
Yeah.
Maybe he's a fan of...
Are my dokey girls come here?
I will turn you to stone and put you in my collection.
I'll have you here.
We got this.
Oh, it's a baby ball.
It's a baby.
Maybe this is one of our viewers.
Is he just going to do that all day?
Oh, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, to the right, to the right, see this oh my god don't go back oh it's pacifier oh wait it's a giant baby yeah did we say our age demographic it might be a viewer did we die oh we were supposed to jump in the hole wait did you jump in the hole yeah i did jump in the hole oh i did not jump in the hole that's okay queen i i i understand i have to i have to test it out you know i need a way what if that was a secret ending exactly right we're we're known for doing very good playthroughs of games every ending exactly that every like playthrough you know what i'm that that's right okay and then we got jumped in fingernails all right down we go down we go oh it's just a tiny tunnel we're like rats oh i keep forgetting to crawl oh do you slide cool we there is a slide we
How'd you do that?
It's cool.
Oh, oh, you run.
Oh, my God, slide dash.
Wait.
How do you do that?
You run.
You hold X and this starts slide dashing.
Did you know I used my keyboard wrong?
Wait, what?
So I can't.
I use my ring finger to press W.
Ring finger?
What does that even look like?
Because, you know, like, typing, you keep, like, your index finger on F.
Yeah.
I learned how to type before I gained, so I used type.
every oh oh i took yeah and so uh oh that's part of the reason why i have skill issues okay i gotta start bashing it get it queen bam yeah dokey bash she just ulted she pressed q yeah i'm ulting i'm ulting oh oh oh careful don't make daddy angry i'm sorry
okay oh i don't like that oh wait that is so it's a cut scene which i i thought it was real oh my god oh oh oh what do we do what do we even do please don't eat us please don't no oh my god is this for maybe it likes us oh okay it's the freaking toy story meme We were in a coma!
The coma theory is real!
Hey, where are you?
Wait, where am I?
Do you see me or you?
I didn't see you.
Because you had the long hair.
Yeah.
What?
Oh.
I don't want to...
The baby said I don't want to play with you anymore the freaking toy story meme oh wait what oh so like oh I think it's like escapism because like you have a trauma or something and then you like went under your bed and went back into your dream world it's like yeah the like the it's like the other part of your mind where the trauma manifests yeah yeah oh hey hey am I part of the are you real yeah am I real Am I part of the trauma?
Is this collab real?
Dad was never real.
TV.
Be honest, someone said the doll looks like me.
Is it true?
Are you lagging?
I think she disconnected, guys.
I think she got replaced with an AI.
Lookie.
Oh, that chicken.
Oh, chicken.
Oh, hey.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit, don't jump down.
We have both LWs.
Real deep.
Don't worry, it was all a dream.
It was a coma theory.
Oh, yeah.
It's fine.
It's like Pokemon, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
All right.
Don't go this way.
Look at all the drawings.
No!
Oh, wait, you're alive.
Okay.
No, I died.
Oh, oh, it restarts you.
No, there was a very loud crunch.
Maybe it fixed my spine.
Oh, yeah, maybe.
We straightened it.
We did it, guys.
We cured scoliosis.
Dude, it's awesome.
My back is not...
Oh!
Okay, um...
No one say anything.
Something...
What?
Something... Oh, you thought I could reset my game.
Did you die?
No, I got, like, teleported somehow.
What did you do?
I was down here walking around, and then my screen was black.
Oh, that's so weird.
I'm not scared of this motherfucker.
What's you gonna do, huh?
Ah!
No!
Tokey help.
I thought it was AFK.
So, um, yeah, that's what it...
it did to me oh oh
maybe you gotta use the umbrella no we out walk out the light oh maybe it'll block the light look never mind don't do not i don't think that's the right answer i i let's get back no
it's my bad internet i got two uploading now yeah yeah yeah she's just lagging right now she's just lagging at the moment I'm lagging, can you hear me?
Hello?
What do we do then?
Okay, I'm gonna follow you.
Why is she so mean?
Did no one love her as a child?
Maybe Coco Melon got canceled.
Oh, we got to wait.
I think we just had to wait.
Right?
Hey, Coco, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, wait.
We gotta put on dancing fruit videos.
Go.
I thought I could go behind the triangle.
I was wrong.
Wait, I think I can.
Oh, break.
I think we just hesitated.
Oh, wait.
I don't want to pattern now.
We hesitated a little bit too much.
She sees the equation.
I see it.
I see the numbers.
The numbers are clicking.
Oh, my God.
The numbers.
341, 4159, 265358979323846647950.
I see the numbers.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Just wait a little.
How do we hit the bridge?
I know, standing.
Oh, there you go.
And then we just move.
Stay here.
You safely, safely.
And then we go, we go, we go, we go, we go, we go.
Oh my god.
We go, we go, we go.
Why was it like in the server?
And then...
Move, move, move.
Move.
You're so thick right now.
Oh, hey, baby.
Open it, don't!
I've never heard a girl say that the mirror's so thick right now.
Yeah, oh, dude.
Okay.
I think...
Oh, we have to push this.
Yeah, I went to pull.
I'm doing it.
I'm pulling.
She's pulling?
Do you know I just recited, like, 40 digits of pie?
I know 3.14.
Yeah.
Half set.
You know, like, pie day?
Oh, like, the food or the number?
Uh, well, both.
So, like, uh, March, what was it?
March?
I baked the pie last month.
Oh, nice.
What kind of pie was it?
Pizza pie.
Oh.
So, on pie day, my school did a thing where you can recite 100 digits of pie.
You can pie any teacher you want.
Did you do it?
Yeah, I did that.
Did it in, like, two days.
I memorized it in two days because I hated this teacher in my school.
That's awesome, dude.
I was like...
That's based.
I inspired me that petty.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So there was a teacher I really fucking hated.
I was like, this is it.
This is the one opportunity I can get.
Stupid baby doesn't know how to look up.
Yeah, gamers don't look up.
Ugh.
Oh!
I...
What happened?
Are you okay?
Oh.
What's up?
How you doing?
I think I know what happened.
How's your day?
We have a good day today, Doki.
Wait, where did you go?
Surprise!
Oh, wait on me.
I thought you were there.
I was gonna surprise you.
It is I.
Oh my god, wait.
Someone was having a good time.
I don't think they were.
I think that's actually the opposite.
Someone was having a good time.
Look at that.
You know what this is.
He wants walkies.
Someone was having too good.
Oh.
It's time to learn how to tie a rope.
Well, I've been here before.
Oh, wait, wait.
What?
We can talk about it.
Let's move on.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I got to shoot that rope over there
Shoot that rope over there.
I have to shoot my rope.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's Bell Tick tock.
Tick tock.
Bong, bong, bong, bong, bong.
Oh, oh, oh, here get in the box.
Get in the box.
Oh Hit the box!
Hit the box!
Get the box!
There's the box!
It's like, what box are you talking about?
No, it was like the sacks.
You can't see it.
Okay, here we go.
That's it.
It's like it never happened.
It was all dream, remember?
It's a coma thing.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
NLR, NLR.
Yeah, yeah.
You might as well cut that out too.
Sorry.
Editors, cut this out.
Cut that out.
Editors, cut that out.
Editors, keep this in.
Alright, bong!
So when my chat just said, my fedora stinks.
Yeah, I know you were fedora.
My fedora stinks!
Oh, there she goes.
Why is she so angry?
Your mama didn't hug her enough?
Same.
My dad didn't.
Oh man, that sucks, man.
I know.
Get back, get back!
Oh.
Oh, Taco Bell!
It's like new toy!
No!
He's stimming.
She's stimming.
It's stimming.
I don't...
I'm scared.
They're stimming.
Boom!
Wait, what do we do here?
Oh, maybe down here?
Oh, here.
No?
Can we jump over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Where's our...
yellow paint when we need it i dude i hate to say it i'm i love yellow paint in games because i get so lost like it's so bad so either a map or yellow paint or like we're not progressing anywhere oh oh we get to do another fidget spin that fidget oh is it time is it wrench time all right wrench time let's come in the microwave i'm committed to the bit
Oh.
Oh, yes.
Oh, okay.
That's okay.
I'll get it done in enough time.
Did you get it done?
I...
Oh, you're back really fast.
Did you get it done?
Yeah?
I'll get it done.
Watch this, boys.
All right.
What is there up to...
I'm so bad at the freaking...
The stupid umbrella.
It's so stupid.
I'm so bad at it.
It's stupid.
It's so stupid.
I'm actually trying.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
The more you say it, the less I'm starting to believe that you're trying.
Here, I opened the lever.
I think you can come up now.
All right.
Oh, there's a ladder on your left.
It's a ladder?
Yes.
Oh, I see.
I see it.
Here, it's right here.
Oh, hey.
got better.
I'm sure I'm sure they were the ladders.
Did you find it?
Alright, cool, I got you.
Alright, I'm heading up.
Wait, are you up top right now?
No, I died.
Fire!
It's fire!
I wanted to make sure you saw it.
It's just hard to notice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You want to make sure...
You know, like, sometimes maybe there won't be fall damage next time, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You gotta test it all out.
Gotta know which one has fall damage and which one doesn't.
Maybe one day you're just, suddenly you're just going to start floating, you know?
You don't know that.
How do you know gravity works every time?
I'm going to ascend to the heavens.
Exactly.
Oh.
They got, look at this.
They got salt.
Or like, is that ashes?
I think that's just rock.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Get your breath.
It's E, okay, it's E.
Okay, okay, okay, stop asking myself.
Okay, okay.
E, E.
Boom.
Wait, put it away!
Okay.
Here you go.
Just go for it.
And then you take it down.
You did it!
Yay!
You learned.
Thank you.
I did.
You learned.
What did you learn today, Chibi?
E is umbrella.
Yay!
All right.
Doing where I got you.
Click that link, guys.
I'm going to click the link pin in our chats.
I feel like something bad is going to happen right here.
I don't...
I think it's fine.
Oh, we're good.
Oh, we have to go...
Maybe...
We have to go here.
Yeah, let's go through this room.
At least there's no giant baby.
For now.
Oh, right here, right here.
Oh, our...
Tito.
Oh, alright.
Oh, thanks.
Alright.
I'll be...
Oh, I gotta help.
Oh, we got white.
Come on.
We got white paint.
How do I grab you?
I think you have to go up yourself.
Yeah, I think you have to go up yourself.
Okay.
I'll be back.
And then she never came back.
I
don't have depth perception.
I felt it's not a joke.
I actually found it.
There's no depth all right.
It's my turn.
You've lost your privilege Up you go queen All right, you missed the jump.
There you go.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, I need to know how you fell down from oh, okay I Look at like if you go to the right it's like yeah, oh, yeah Sorry, um, no, it's like yeah, it's like it's like I liked a little bit like okay Okay, I liked a little bit.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, see doodle.
Sorry I think my stream died a little too because of the lag.
Oh, sorry guys.
I'm back.
Guys, I'm back guys.
Oh, thank goodness.
Okay, cool.
Please don't turn into a smear.
Please don't fall.
Okay, no, it's your turn.
It's your turn.
One of us will get it right.
What?
Okay, okay.
You missed also.
Sorry, I got excited.
I got excited.
I just love the sound of the, like the...
Like a...
Alright, let's see.
Alright, my turn to watch you.
I think I gotta pull this.
Oh, you gotta grab this rope!
Yeah, yeah.
And then... We're team!
Wee!
This is awesome!
It's like, this is like a team game.
I'm taking a shortcut.
down what happens if i'm under here okay wait let's try that yeah let's see what happens oh i can slowly crush you wow i can't wait uh checking my apple watch i can't i can't scroll back i can't slowly crush it's my aura you can it's just i have aura and so it doesn't move past it that was awesome it's this chick games did you see that she like canceled out the fall damage oh yeah yeah we do this oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we pull this i feel like we're like the two like two different sides of the spectrum of gamers you're like the like professional like talented lady and then i'm just here because i fall it's like no you're like it's like i play uh shooters and you played mine i suck at mine sweeper how did wait what do you know the rules of mine sweeper I only recently learned how to play like a year ago and I never gave I tried once and I died so I never played again yeah you blocked me you blocked me you your fat head blocked me what the fake what the fake I think I think that's just
skill different that's a skill issue I will you're actually allowed to say that because you are in every way objectively better than me at every video game you could think So yes, you can say that to me.
No one else can't chat.
Shut the frick up.
You guys lose at Webkins.
Ah!
We forgot to shoot the rope.
Oh.
I just got to shoot my shoot rope.
Wait, how do you lose at Webkins?
There's like, there's like Goober's like a bunch of games in it.
You know, they lose it then.
They're bad.
The wheel of wow, they don't even get a prize.
The wheel of what?
Yeah, and the wishing well.
They don't get any.
It was gambling for toddlers, the wishing law.
Oh, did you got to teach them young, you know?
Yeah, exactly, dude.
I get it.
I start itching whenever I can't.
Shoot that.
I got nervous to shoot.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
Oh, baby man, baby upsetting spaghetti.
Oh, freaking grabbed me.
Bro, the box like grazed you and you just had a heart attack.
Dude, it squished my head.
You know, oh, it's like that little baby bump where you're not supposed to touch a specific bump on the baby or they'll just like well babies are like made of like mostly the material and wait i thought i was you sorry anyways i had i just associated i thought it was you i was like dang i nailed that jump yeah maybe i am a baby like a lot of cartilage yeah yeah exactly so like it like that's why babies you can't leave them if you have a flat head it means your mom and daddy didn't hold you enough as a baby because you're you have a flat head i don't my mom actually i'm scared you did We need to stop talking because I'm like walking in on our conversation You have one job one job in this entire assignment I'm scared.
I'll go and you go okay.
All right, all right, I swear on my parents and like their graves I don't I jump did it did not work.
I swear on like the hearts and the souls of my parents I swear on the souls of my parents What?
The squash of my head!
Did they work?
All right, you go first.
You go first.
Ah!
All right.
Yeah, you know what to do next.
Cool.
All right, and then you go.
Come on.
Don't get the squash.
Don't have her squash your head.
I know.
I'm staying with you.
Staying with you.
All right, and now we go, right?
Now we go.
Yeah.
You're in the...
Oh, freak.
No!
How do we do this?
Now you go, now you go, now you go, oh!
Don't go!
And eventually we'll get past the stage.
We'll get past the stage eventually.
Can't be that hard, right?
I got my umbrella.
Alright.
Now shoot that.
Boom.
Let him stim.
Let the baby stim a little bit.
The square hole goes into the square hole.
All right.
We don't go yet.
I'm scared.
Oh.
Oh, no.
You're so brave.
I should have gone.
Don't get.
I'm scared.
Don't get scared.
And now there was one.
Oh, my gosh.
It's in the box.
No.
I went so far.
Did you see it?
I my fat giant grotesque focal pop ahead hit the side of the box What how does it hit the side look at your look at your head?
Have you not seen my head in real life?
I okay, I'm not I swear I I look like I I I'm about to punch my monitor I pulled out the bow I pulled out the bow and you can't jump with the bow you go first you go first you go first Okay, I'll wait here.
Tell me when you're at the other side Like I die or Tell me, okay, like, tell me when you're done with this level.
Okay, I'll wait here.
And I go, right?
I'll wait here.
I'm going to lie back in my chair and close my eyes.
Until you get it right.
Did you get it right?
And now I go, right?
I go now.
You go now.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm closing my eyes.
Close your eyes until you get it right.
Ha, ha, ha.
I did it!
Oh, my God.
I did it.
That's all it took.
All right, I'm heading over now.
Don't worry.
Daddy's coming He's coming home.
He's got the- Yay!
I'm coming home!
I wish this happened in real life.
You coming home, not like getting like- Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Not like being like, you know, murdered.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That would Loki suck.
Yeah, I think like, you know, being murdered might not be like the funnest thing in the world.
That would not be a Potter's moment.
Yeah, I feel like- Oh!
Oh!
You gotta run, you gotta run.
I got hydraulic pressed.
It's just, you know, it's hard to run when, you know, we're just so, like, weighed down, you know, by our traveler.
If you got hydraulic pressed, what do you think would pop out?
I think, like, a bunch of bubbles would come out if you got hydraulic pressed.
Or, like, some, like, balloons.
Me?
Or you?
They're like feathers, because you're a bird.
Oh, that's true.
I think for you, it'll be, like, you know, have you ever watched Honey Boo Boo?
Yes, yes, I feel like one episode.
I feel like, wait, if you ever get hydraulic press, you just like...
I guess we'll never know.
I guess we'll just never know.
I need to get my older brother to plug in the controller.
Listen, listen, listen, listen.
We need to, we need to...
Guys.
I got bad bees.
I'm getting a little...
Yeah, she just left.
She's just lagging IRL and then I in game, you know?
Jump!
You got this, you got this, you got this.
We can- we can escape!
Do you want to jump?
We're gonna find a jump!
There's one more jump!
Oh, it's gonna take this off!
There's another jump!
Jump here!
Jump here, jump here!
Oh, oh, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Boom!
It'll never find us.
here that's right behind the box behind box yeah yeah at least she'll get she's gonna grab the the shaker well what is that awesome point oh it's like a little it's like a baby hammer
oh no she's gonna do kill us no oh gosh you need to fight the turkey bro you need new hair oh Oh, the birds!
Oh, the birds!
The birds!
I got my bow out.
They heard our prayers!
Yeah, get out of here.
Go my chickens!
Go birds!
Kill her!
Kill the baby!
Yeah.
See, and all babies deserve to live.
Well, I mean, especially if they have, like, death laser eyeballs.
That's kind of like...
Like, I mean, like, if your baby is going to turn out to be, like, a serial killer, like, like, would you really let your baby grow old?
You know, I mean, like, I don't know.
Us, we're losing a 1v1 to a toddler.
Well, it's a 1v2.
Yeah, but a murderer toddler.
So that's, like, three of us.
Not the drug, the item.
What?
Oh.
Pot!
How do I throw it?
I don't think I can throw it.
Sweet!
Whoa!
This is Rocket League.
Oh, we gotta go down this way.
Oh, this way.
Oh, creepy.
What is this?
Oh, yeah.
This way.
Oh, this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a hole.
Oh my god, look.
There's more pods.
Let's see how deep the hole is.
I did not hear the pot break, but I heard a...
What the fuck?
You know like how like people in like mines will drop a rock to see how far?
I heard your body.
Like hold on, like on pause, let me show you, listen to listen to this.
Like hold up, listen to the delayed crunch.
Like oh, what's not here?
Let me join you.
another crunch i'm alive well what's this my god i'm beautiful really yeah come down here wait really okay i'm down if i die i'm mad at you okay wait how are you alive how did you do that the friend try again no you have to land on like a mirror you see this mirror you had to land on it which side is on the left it's on the right it's on the right okay oh come on Did it?
Wait, I did it!
I landed on it!
No, you didn't.
I didn't see your body.
Wait, so, like, I have to land and, like, bounce off it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm aiming.
I'm aiming.
Boom.
Oh.
Okay.
I don't think you aimed it.
Can you be so thorough with me?
Do I have to use the umbrella?
Be honest with me.
Watch this.
I'm going to use the umbrella.
Last minute.
boom you are disgusting I you what do you mean GV sometimes you gotta be able to think for years I'm here to teach you a life less sorry my hands are shaking I was getting nervous how is this how is this on me sometimes you gotta think for yourself I'm not grabbing that hat I saw what you did.
I saw what you did, like, but...
I'm just, look, I'm just cleaning it.
Grab my hand.
Come on.
Let's go.
Let's...
We're gonna go meet football.
That's an adventure time reference.
Oh, I do.
Wow.
Okay, the worst you can say is no.
She said, do I have to?
Oh!
Oh, no way in, no way out.
I don't think we can go out now.
Go back.
I want to be monkey.
Are you okay?
I'm dying.
Please.
No!
Fulfill my final wish.
What's your final wish?
Conquer Mars.
Really?
How would I do that?
Wait, how do I do that?
I got beans!
Don't worry, I got to do it.
You must.
Eat this.
I thought a blueberry.
Oh, there's a blueberry.
Wait, wait, why is there?
Oh, I think we're, like, in somebody's, like, stash.
Maybe, yeah, this is, like, someone's secret hideout.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, we're breaking in.
Wait, this looks like the vent from the old games.
Are we back in, like, the...
Filled my final wish.
Remember to click on the link.
Been in my chat.
Oh, no, I think we're back on the ship.
Yeah.
Filled my final wish.
me i'm scared i think we're back on the ship it's not swaying though so maybe we're back in the city baby oh oh wait oh it's like those people carrier they got too fat oh i'll get you i'm coming oh wait does it reset for both of us yeah oh my god okay guy okay now that we know that gravity is real i really didn't like that bug part i'm glad that was just a dream yeah thank god i was just a just a very bad dream okay so you have to so you have to grab this yeah little pipes careful i'm back oh i can't have my umbrella go uppity uppers dude i kind of wish this transport system was real i'd love to get around i know i know right like it's be awesome i feel like that's just so convenient you know like okay it's like the old people elevator yeah yeah yeah so like you're from and i feel like it'd be cheaper than than Uber,
too.
Just bring your phone.
Just bring your phone and just, you know, browse Twitter while you're on it.
Yeah, dude, it's me and the bros in the creative mode.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's so true.
That's so true.
Like, me and my homies hang out.
All right, so I wonder where that goes.
I wonder where that goes, though.
Like, I don't know.
They seem like they like it, though.
Yeah.
Like, they're pretty chill.
Yeah, I don't know.
They don't seem like they don't like everything.
Yeah, I think they're having a good time.
Yeah, just hang it.
Just hang it.
Well, guys, it seems we are, I want, for those who want to know where this goes, it seems like our time.
Oh,
GV?
How'd you scream?
Hey, are you good?
Hello.
I just...
Wait, how did you do that, though?
How did you do that?
What?
How did she do this?
Wait, is it just you?
Oh my god, only you do it.
You can do it.
I'm so nervous.
Oh my god.
I'm just nervous to be hanging out with a cute girl.
I'm shaking a lot.
Yeah.
Oh, am I getting my tremors again?
I'm getting...
I'm such a big fan.
Oh, what's that over there?
I'm just gonna look over here real quick.
Hello?
Oh, we turn around.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Go...
Stand like this.
Okay, okay.
Like this?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Stand like this.
You can sit face front.
I like how you walk away like you're ashamed
Okay, okay, let's move on Let's
cut that out Okay, okay, let's Very serious let's play guys Come on, it's a very serious It's very certain.
Okay, move, move, move, move, move, move, move, move, move, move.
Move.
All right.
Anyway, as I was saying.
Yes, your monologue, yes.
As I was saying, everybody, if you guys want to find out where...
I'm supposed to...
My hand, what the...
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, come back.
Wait, that was funny.
Wait.
nervous okay okay what does it look like when we hold hands actually oh wait wait that's really cute oh wait i can't drag you anywhere wait what's the purpose of holding your hand being being friends oh i'm holding my hand over here can i pull you how do i pull yeah that's what i'm saying How do we pull each other?
I'm a chicken.
Alright, pull me.
I don't...
Anyway guys!
Anyway...
Anyway guys.
To find out where those elevators are gonna go!
I can't get in the hole.
Tune in next time to part two.
Yo, I'm actually I'm not even just saying this was sponsored.
This is really good so far.
I've been so fun.
I've enjoyed it.
Yeah, it makes me, like, I'm really curious about the world.
The world building.
I like that it's kind of mixing.
Like, it feels like.
It makes me want to, like, look more into the old games, too.
I feel like this is going to be connected.
Yeah, like, I'm really interested.
Yeah, because I'm like, where does this?
Wait, wait, they're not dead.
Wait, this.
They're not dead.
Look at them.
Yeah, no, they're alive.
Yeah, this is actually, like, the people transport.
click our links yeah or everybody remember uh if you want to if you want to check out the game remember to click on the link pinned in our chat and in the description thank you bandai for sponsoring us we've enjoyed the game so far and hope you guys have enjoyed more doki doki streams because this is the last one don't worry we're gonna we're gonna continue more next week yeah doki is my friend reading yeah yeah like like on paper yes oh yeah yeah i'm Prepare to be here every minute,
but it's worth it, guys.
Woo-hoo!
But we hope y'all enjoyed it.
We hope y'all enjoyed it so far.
But yes, thank you again to Bandai for the sponsor.
Please feel free.
It's all available on...
No!
Okay, here's a little test, Cheeby.
What platforms is it available on?
Yes.
It wasn't a yes or no question.
It is available now.
It is available on PlayStation, Xbox, PC, and Switch.
A free friend's pass is included.
Oh wait, no, I'm not supposed to read that.
Wait, no, I am.
A free friend's pass is included to make it even easier for you to play with a friend on the same platform in online co-op.
Or you can play solo with an AI companion.
Shake it out using my link.
Or my link.
Or my link as well, you know?
But yeah, thank you again, everyone.
Thank you.
Thank you for sponsoring us.
We hope you all enjoyed it.
We will be playing longer next time, the next week.
So yeah, we'll be checking out the game.
You don't really need to play with...
We don't need to play with a friend.
Did you just jump off again?
I'm a victim.
Oh, what?
What are you a victim of?
I got pushed off.
By who?
What pushed you off, Tivi?
You did.
Wait, wait, wait.
We want to see something cool up here.
Yeah, sure.
I want to see something cool up.
Wait, I don't have my umbrella anymore.
Do you?
Oh, I don't.
Wait, I think...
Wait, why would your umbrella?
I wanted to use it and jump off and see where I'd go.
I don't think...
Oh, maybe, like, we can use the umbrella, like...
Yeah, maybe it's like an area specific.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fair enough, because I bet you could, like, get to places you're not supposed to.
Yeah, yeah.
So you don't want to, like, you know, bug that out or anything.
Yeah.
But yeah.
Thank you everyone for watching.
Are you gonna talk to your chat now?
Yeah!
Wait, sorry, what did you say?
Oh, I said I'm gonna talk to you chat?
Yeah.
I might go play more Mega Block.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Do you like that game?
Uh, yeah, that's pretty good.
I'm like a little, I'm a little addicted to it.
I just started playing.
I've only played it once.
Do you have any advice for me?
Um.
Don't die.
I got it.
Got it.
Everyone write that down.
If you don't die, you'll get the high score.
I got top 1 million.
You got top 1 million?
I did.
Top 99 percentile.
That's good, right?
I'm proud of you.
Thank you.
I beat level 1.
Hey, everyone.
Thank you all for coming to the stream.
I always have a very good time, so it's very fun today.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Me too.
Or next time.
And we'll play more.
I'm really excited.
Yeah, let's all say bye to Chibi.
And I guess bye to me too from Chibi's chat.
Remember to click on the link.
Pin in our chat.
And in our description.
Oh, I have a...
Oh, goodbye.
Oh,
I look the way from my screen.
I just heard a...
Oh!
But yeah, thank you again, everyone.
But yeah, I'll leave you to your chat now.
We'll be having a good rest of your day.
Yeah, you too.
You too.
I heard you've been streaming a lot, so we can get some rest.
Yeah, no, I had, I had, like, a 14, like, maybe, like, almost 20-plus hours stream in the span of, like, a day and a half.
What were you addicted to?
What were you using Marvel Rivals?
I wouldn't say.
Oh, I see.
I don't know.
If there's anything.
I'll see you later, TV.
Have fun with your chat.
Hello.
I hope.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, she wanted to talk more.
Oops.
I got it out.
I thought.
I thought I want to say bye-bye.
She's like, bye.
I thought I thought the conversation.
it might have accidentally hung up on her um but thank you all for coming um thank you all for checking out the today's sponsor stream thank you again to bandai for for sponsoring i was appreciated i hope you guys enjoyed little nightmares too and i hope you guys had a great time Square again and please again like I said check out um Little Nightmares 2 um on um on PlayStation Steam um uh Switch Xbox uh oh yeah Siemens and PC as you guys know yeah I really appreciate you click on the link uh sorry Little Nightmares 3 Little Nightmares 3 account account I learned account today I check out Little Nightmares 3 It's because there were two of us.
I was thinking dokey dokey.
So I was thinking two.
But I meant little nightmares three.
But thank you, everyone, again.
As always, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you know she's tired.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
But we guys all had a great time.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you said for me, especially today, because I think a lot of people stayed up for a very long time, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.